[Applaudissements]
soyez convaincus d'une chose
c'est que mon discours est d'un
optimisme de combat
je n'aime pas trop les optimistes
crédules mais je revendique ceux qui se
battent pour ce que je vais essayer de
vous démontrer
j'ai eu le privilège depuis 40 ans
d'accompagner des entrepreneurs
j'ai mis 250 je pense que c'est
largement plus que 250 qui étaient des
patrons européens
en appliquant une règle qui est celle de
l'analyse financière
c'est-à-dire d'aller chercher derrière
les chiffres derrière l'apparence
quelle est la réalité
et je dois dire que j'ai été stupéfait
par ce que nous avons tous constaté
qu'il y à une sorte de banalisation
à dire bois voulu on est dans un épisode
de croissance à crédit très bien
mais posons la question et s'il n'y
avait pas le crédit qu'y at il
et c'est cette stupéfaction que j'ai
découverte
c'est que si on prend un le cas de la
france
dans les quarante ans qui ont précédé la
pandémie
s'il n'y avait pas eu ce crédit la
france aurait été en récession
mot
terrifiant
mais qui correspond à une réalité certes
hypothétique mais qui est une réalité et
nous ne sommes pas les seuls en fait les
etats-unis sont dans une situation
encore plus grave que la nôtre et dans
mon échantillon j'ai également pris le
cas du royaume uni
et le chiffre que vous voyez que vous
pouvez faire par vous même avec les
données de la banque mondiale et de
s'aider eux c'est que dans cette période
là de 40 ans pour générer 1 % de
croissance
il fallait augmenter la dette de 2 %
cette situation bien entendu n'est pas
soutenable
mais par contre elle nous éclaire en
tout cas elle m'a éclairé
sur pour moi une espèce de de
métamorphose
le poète dirait nuitamment et sans bruit
parce que personne ne l'a vu cette
métamorphose
et pourtant elle est vraie c'est à dire
que pendant les deux siècles qui ont été
de la machine à vapeur aux trente
glorieuses
on a connu ce camp en analyse financière
on appelle
une prospérité organique et le mode
organique en anglais veut dire bio
oui nos aïeux ont connu une prospérité
bio une prospérité naturel une propriété
inclusive
et chose étonnante c'est que c'est au
moment où
cette prospérité s'est infléchie et nous
verrons pourquoi après dans les années
soixante à soixante dix que nom n'a
littéralement
sacraliser le mot de croissance
personnes dans les deux siècles
précédents n'avaient utilisé ce mot de
croissance on parler d'expansion par les
progrès on parlait de développement mais
pas de cette croissance donc c'est au
moment même où elle s'est mise en déclin
que ce mot de 307 indicateurs de
croissance est devenue la boussole de
nos existences
étant donné que cette croissance est
maintenant
tributaire d'un accroissement qui lui
est supérieur de la dette
je prends la liberté de dire que nous
nous sommes passés à une prospérité
toxiques
cette prospérité toxiques en fait pour
en comprendre la profondeur
il faut regarder ce qui est inadmissible
l'inadmissible c'est que la cause
profonde de la croissance et c'est à
dire avant de la prospérité c'est les
gains de productivité
ces gains de productivité
à partir des années 70
ont décliné
alors il ya eu un sursaut
que ma génération a connu certains dans
la salle ont connu c'est celle de de
l'arrivée d'internet dans la vie
économique
et aujourd'hui on se raccroche à cet
épisode de sursaut dans le déclin
qui est inadmissible
inacceptable
parce que toutes les politiques sont sur
la croissance qui est elle même
construit sur l'idée que cette
productivité va revenir
les néolibéraux ont voulu forcer le
destin et ils ont concocté
une chose mais une sorte de potion
magique en mélangeant la technologie
beaucoup de croissance de la dette de
création monétaire et un soupçon
d'activisme financiers le but recherché
c'était ce fameux effet richesse que les
banquiers centraux ont officiellement
annoncé comme étant le but de leur
politique
avec une espérance
que cet effet richesse engendrée
le fameux ruissellement par lequel la
richesse viendrait irriguer l'ensemble
de nos économies ça n'a pas été le cas
on a simplement obtenu un effet
patrimoine qui d'ailleurs est
strictement est directement
proportionnel au niveau de croissance de
l'endettement
quelles sont les conséquences
j'en retiens trois la première c'est
montre oignons pommes parce que c'est
l'épuisement des ressources naturelles
et toute la problématique climatique qui
va derrière
c'est l'enjeu du siècle ne nous trompons
pas le deuxième ce sont les crises
financières il y en aura une quand
comment de quelle ampleur
personne ne le sait mais il y en aurait
eu parce que c'est dans la nature même
de notre système
mais c'est pas la peine je veux vous
entendez je vais vous emmener sur
pour moi le risque le plus grave qui est
le retour du dialogue mais lien de quoi
s'agit-il
dans sa guerre contre ce parc il ya
exactement deux mille cinq cents hors
athènes débarque sur l'île de melior ou
mais l'os et les mets liens commencent
ce que thucydide a appelé un dialogue le
dialogue mais lien
les maliens disent mais vous n'avez pas
besoin de nous conquérir on est des
gentils on est pacifiste on n'a pas
d'armes et en plus on est neutres donc
vous pouvez passer votre chemin
la sentence eu monstrueuse
les ont été exterminés et les femmes et
les enfants réduit en esclavage
comment athènes la mère patrie de la
démocratie
at-elle pu entériner
à cette époque là que c'est le rapport
de force qui doit être le rapport
dominant
et c'est contre ce dialogue mais liens
que les deux mille ans qui ont suivi de
l'occident chrétien
ont essayé de contenir de réduire et
d'espérer une éradication de ce rapport
avec l'arrivée par les lumières de
l'état de droit de la notion du comprend
du débat et non pas du rapport de force
gvep ça parce que la prospérité
vertueuse que j'ai décrit précédemment a
été le dernier terreau nécessaire
à réaliser
ce que je considère comme un
chef-d'oeuvre c'est le vivre ensemble
cette notion moderne
d'inclusivité de respect de l'autre de
prospérité commune de biens communs etc
certes c'était le résultat d'une pensée
mais c'était surtout le résultat de deux
siècles d'une prospérité vertueuse
à partir du moment où on est passé d'une
prospérité vertueuse à une prospérité
toxiques
je dis qu'il y à un risque de ne plus
connaître ce ce vivre ensemble dont nous
pouvons être très fiers
je peux pas accepter
le fait que lily et 7 cette espèce de
condamnation
alors je vous propose
quelques raids la première c'est
d'admettre que nos politiques sont dans
l'impasse
pourquoi parce que je les côtoie à
bruxelles à paris aux états unis au
canada ils ont un raisonnement
parfaitement vigoureux mais sur un
postulat qui est faux qui n'est plus
celui de la réalité
la deuxième chose c'est d'admettre
l'absurde
nous entendons mais pas seulement en
france mais dans toute l'europe et même
aux états unis que la dette qui ne cesse
de croître
serait
remboursé par une croissance qui est
elle même dépendante de l'augmentation
de la dette
nous savons que les raisonnements
circulaire ne marche pas
que faire
je propose de revenir aux fondamentaux
du libéralisme
est pour ca de resterez trois choses
la première c'est de ne pas faire ce que
l'on a tendance aujourd'hui à faire qui
est de confondre la notion de progrès
avec la notion d'innovation ou de
technologie non le produit avec un p
majuscule c'est ce que victor hugo a
défendu en 1848 à l'assemblée nationale
c'est un progrès immense c'est celui qui
permet aux êtres humains de sortir de la
souffrance on a toujours cru que c'était
de la misère non de la souffrance ça
c'est le progrès et il faut que ça
redevienne l'objectif la deuxième chose
il ne peut pas y avoir de libéralisme
s'il n'y a pas une économie de marché et
une économie de marché ça veut dire une
régulation forte et il n'y a pas de
régulation forte s'il n'y a pas des
sanctions proportionnelles aux entraves
qui sont faites aujourd'hui sous nos
yeux à la libre concurrence
troisième recommandation c'est la
légitimité du capitalisme c'est le coeur
de mon métier
cette légitimité elle a toujours été
d'être proportionnelle que sa
rémunération soit proportionnelle aux
risques pris par l'investisseur
ce n'est plus le cas de toronto à
singapour on est aujourd'hui avec un
capitalisme mondial qui recherchent les
rendements du risque sans prendre de
risques
pour conclure
c'est cette photo c'est l' enthousiasme
qu'elle dégage de ce vivre ensemble
est ce que je vis en tant que banquier
c'est que
c'est une suggestion mais c'est que ce
n'est plus un problème économique on
veut le traité comme un problème
économique non c'est fini nous sommes
face à un problème
anthropologique
voix défaut psychologiques sociologiques
mais ce n'est plus du ressort de
l'économie et pour conclure il ya une
astuce parce qu'il va falloir pas mal
d'années pour que l'on arrive à passer
d'une idée à la prise en compte dans les
politiques de cette réalité
l'astuce et les simples et je les ai
expérimenté au niveau des entreprises
c'est que si le cap
s'appelle la pérennité et non pas la
croissance immédiate des résultats
les entreprises que j'ai accompagné y
compris certaines communautés urbaines
traverse toutes les crises sans dommage
[Applaudissements]